You say I don't know I'm beautiful, but what if I did?
What if I looked in the mirror and actually liked what I saw?
Makeup or no makeup, flaws and all.
What if I woke up really feeling myself...
...and could post a selfie to Instagram without any self doubt?
No questions, contemplations or hesitations...
...because the only person's confirmation I would need is my own.
You say I don't know I'm beautiful, but what if I did?
What if I accepted compliments at face value...
...instead of constantly feeling the need to devalue myself for the sake of someone else.
No, stop.
You're just saying that to be nice.
You're just saying that because you're my friend.
If you've ever caught yourself saying these words, please take a moment and think again.
Please, take a moment to marvel at the radiance of your beauty,...
...both from the outside and from within.